speaking of knight rider though there
were a lot of like stunts did you do
any of this done yeah yeah well i did i
got really good at driving
because i wanted to and uh the reverse
180 is
i could teach you right in about five
minutes
we had no cgi and we did everything of
the seat of our pants
and the best part about it was they
would have 40 guys out there
paid not to kill me and they would say
action nightmare
and i just go woohoo and i just
do a wd-40 and spray the wheels and spin
out spin through and go through
and then you got paid for that can you
believe it that's amazing
it's incredible would you ever do a
reboot
there's a reboot in the making so we'll
see what happens
yeah i actually heard
there was a hoff auction yeah we had an
auction auction
you know i went to the half auction was
like going to my funeral it was like
going to a different
a different time you know it's best just
to get rid of this stuff sell it
give the money to charity which i gave a
lot of money to
the global mobility company which is
makes children walk it has
creates wheelchairs for them yeah i
still have got like four or five
auctions
left i heard that one of your
most prized possessions involves
spongebob yeah one of my prized
possessions in my house
is a 13 and a half foot 750 pound
version of david hasselhoff
i feel like you should just put it right
as you enter your home
[Laughter]
i always think write those people on it
as a mailbox that would be
amazing yep i'm still here just waiting
for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever